boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Alan sakyan
really excited to be on site in Sioux
Falls South Dakota we are at the Zeal
Center for entrepreneurship we are
talking to Dr Aaron Spencer what's up
thanks for coming out of the show really
appreciate it very excited to be having
a conversation about entrepreneurship
about Innovation Aaron is the director
of the University of South Dakota's
Innovation and Entrepreneurship program
and also just has a tremendous amount of
experience with teaching about the skill
sets of innovation of Entrepreneurship
and getting people around the world to
start picking it up and applying it and
it's different ways across
states and countries and and even
individuals and communities because
there's so many different ways to apply
this and I think we're going to end up
talking about that quite a bit
um we have a live audience which is
super exciting because we just finished
doing a talk
um so if you guys want to make some
noise audience
yeah that's what's up I love it I love
it it's great to have a live audience
um so let's unpack a bit about your
background because you were awarded the
Fulbright scholarship and there's like
there's a bunch of other really
interesting things you spent a lot of
time several six years in Russia total
of six years so almost six years in
Russia four years consecutive and then
two previous times for a year each
um and that was mostly focused on
teaching researching and helping promote
entrepreneurship in Russia of course
they don't have a
cultural or historical background of
doing entrepreneurship over there and so
it's a big change
for them
yeah and then and then in the United
States you were at UC Irv Irvine I did
my doctorate at UC Earth at UC Irvine
and then you were doing some also some
very interesting work there with it was
um it was parsing a language and then
that was actually before that before
that that was my undergrad stuff where
we were working with using computer
analysis of text
to determine the answer to the
Shakespeare authorship question but that
was a long time ago yeah yeah
the answer is Shakespeare is in fact
Shakespeare as near as we can tell none
of the other claimants match so yeah but
that computer analysis of text was in
the 80s right uh it was actually early
90s early 90s yeah so that's still
really uh that's a high level
accomplishment in early 90s time is
computer analysis of text and then okay
so then from there how did you start
picking up the interest of wanting to
work with different with teaching
Innovation and Entrepreneurship well
I've been interested in
Innovation entrepreneurship small
business my entire life I mean I started
my first business when I was
nine years old something like that
painting those little numbers on the
side of the curb so the firemen can see
where your house is by the way we need
some of that in Sioux Falls because
there's so many houses you can't tell
where you are right there's no clear
numbers on them but I'll leave that for
some other nine-year-old
nine-year-olds in Sioux Falls
got a business right there yeah so uh
when I was in high school I did a
computer Consulting business helping
local small businesses get computerized
this was
when computers were first really
becoming a big thing the Advent of the
first Laser Printers and stuff like that
um
I did some other stuff I did
some hazardous materials work actually
where we were helping to implement some
of the first computer systems to help
First Responders deal with chemical
spills and things like that
uh and that was all
back when I was a kid really
then
did that stuff with Shakespeare and so
forth when I was in college
and uh
graduated into a recession
so instead of
following where you'd expect based on my
degree I went into database programming
and stuff like that
then after a few years of that I went
back got into the PHD program
and uh did some work related to
primarily how Innovation
entrepreneurship impacts the economy
this is a very interesting it is yeah
and one of the things that I looked at
was
how Innovation could be used to respond
to things like the California
electricity crisis that happened in
2000.
and
things like that I looked at using
Innovation as a response to the
terrorist attacks of 9 11.
and then I after I graduated from Irvine
I was a professor at New Jersey
Institute of Technology yep then
that was like eight years it's a long
time uh seven years there then went to
Russia that when I won the Fulbright in
2010 that was my second year in Russia
that I did that then quickly teach us
about the full break because I thought
that was really cool so the Fulbright
program is a program named after Senator
William Fulbright
and the program is designed to
facilitate International cooperation and
understanding
and there are programs at various levels
so there's undergraduate programs for
like kids from foreign countries to
learn English kids from America to go
over to foreign countries and help teach
English
then there's kind of an intermediate
level where people typically at the
Master's level or focus on doing some
early stage research or something like
that and then there's the scholar
program which is for established
professors to go and teach and research
in their fields of expertise
and a foreign country
you know and that's the program that I
was in and I went to Nova spearsk Russia
and spent a year at Nova sabirsk State
University
which is actually in a little suburb of
novice called academ or academic City
it's where they put all the
people who were too smart to throw on
the camps because they were too valuable
for their smarts but they were too
politically unreliable to keep say
around Moscow or St Petersburg so they
built this special City for them out
middle of Siberia called it academic
City
foreign
you started talking about the the
importance of both International
cooperation uh and and understanding and
also about the impact that Innovation
entrepreneurship have on economics and
how have you seen that through your work
well
one of the uh some of my research for
instance we found that
entrepreneurship is the single biggest
driver of job creation yeah
and high-tech entrepreneurship or
Innovative entrepreneurship is even more
so so small businesses create new jobs
at about three and a half times what you
would expect based on their share of
current employment so
small businesses employ a hundred people
they produce 340 new jobs
proportionally right
oh
like like manufacturing or something
like just broadly speaking it can be
anything from a coffee shop to a law
firm
government government definitions of
size so uh when I say a small business
I'm I'm using fewer than a hundred
employees okay so let's give an example
like isn't maybe uh Taco John's like
about that size maybe let's use that as
an example yeah uh Krispy Kreme Donuts
it started that way right and they
became huge so what is the three and a
half time multiplier related to so
Krispy Kreme for example so if we look
at their share if uh
if small businesses
are in this category are 20 of the
economy
they produce 70 of the new jobs
okay the Pareto application high-tech
small businesses are about 5.8 times
their share of current employment so if
they're five percent they produce about
28 percent
of 20 to 29 of new jobs okay so so the
if you want to look at impact
on the economy
small businesses have a far bigger
impact than big businesses at high tech
or Innovative small businesses haven't
even been higher higher impact and so it
was a percentage of their economic uh
contributions so so when we when we
looked at this time period big
businesses actually lost jobs
medium-sized business this is say 100 to
had fairly small changes a couple
percent either direction
and small businesses is where all of the
growth came from in fact
132 percent of all net job creation
came from small businesses and this was
during a time of like economic
constriction this this covered a period
of growth constriction and a turnaround
so because what years then are we
talking we're looking at 98 through
2002. okay so a very exciting time in
the economy high growth with the end of
the internet boom the crash
obviously the terrorist attacks impacted
the economy then in 2002 we get a a bit
of a recovery from the recession so it
was a time period that covered all sorts
of different types of economic
situations and the interesting thing is
that it
that small business effect was
consistent across all the years
now
in 2001 the high-tech ones did have a
bit of a but only in 2001 itself
what would you attribute what would you
attribute to small businesses being able
to be robust in times of wherever the
economy is going well it's not that any
one small business is robust and that's
the thing about it the important thing
from an economic point of view is that
there's so many of them and people are
trying new things and one of them is
going to work in any given situation and
that's one that ends up
and the problem is with big businesses
you have a much more limited
number of approaches to a situation and
if the circumstances change
some of them are going down
yeah you're going to lose a lot of small
businesses
but the impact of the handful of
successful small businesses
taking advantage of that situation
growing ends up
far outweighing the number of small
businesses that fail
in fact the number of small businesses
that fail is kind of indistinguishable
from the noise because so many start and
fail all the time
right and so one of the beautiful things
about small businesses is they allow us
to try
millions and millions of different
things all the time and find the ones
that actually work interesting so
they're the ones that are doing all the
combinations of business ideas exactly
big scales trying them out yeah if you
look at uh
you know get a little technical like
Joseph schumpeter or Friedrich Hayek
talking about these different models of
how the economy works
well
they're you know kind of the laboratory
the experiments are going on right
and
so some of them are going to find the
right combination the right new
set of innovations that are going to fit
ideally with current circumstances and
then take off like
you know go gangbusters and others are
not right and one of the things we found
is that big businesses just by nature of
being big cannot adapt as fast yeah
and so that adaptability of small
businesses allows them to take advantage
of new situations grow and become
successful
and sometimes what happens is they end
up displacing
an existing large business and becoming
the new whatever right so and that's the
beauty of a dynamic economy like we have
in the United States or at least like we
like to think we have there's been a lot
of pressure to make it less Dynamic and
that's one of the things we have to
resist is you know trying to make things
too safe the regulatory part of its
regulatory part of its attitude some of
its legal you know everybody the one
attitude component there's like there's
no when was the last time we saw like
CNN or Fox News celebrating young kids
being entrepreneurs and we don't see
that the cultures are our approach to
risk-taking has changed too
I mean how many people here were alive
last time a man walked on the moon
we don't even have one yeah yeah
there's a few of you but
last time it happened was 1972.
oh yeah so a couple Yeah couple right
yeah now
we've actually did you know the United
States literally forgot how to make
rocket engines
I mean yeah forget how to fish when
you're not actually using part of part
of the peace dividend after the collapse
of the Soviet Union was we decided to
support the
Russian economy as opposed to the Soviet
Soviet economy by buying rocket engines
from them and we actually completely
shut down all of our capability to do it
here it completely lost that skill set
damn yeah that's that kind of stuff with
production is is kind of scary is that
if you're not natively manufacturing
something you're dependent on another
country you might forget the skill we've
got guys like musk and so forth that are
kind of rebuilding that right now but
it's taken a lot longer than it should
have
because we let that atrophy
but it's not just the shutdown of some
of those skill sets we're unwilling
today to take some of the physical risks
that we took back then
I mean
anybody here seen the movie Apollo 13.
okay
well that was an almost disaster but
what we often forget is
just a little bit before that there was
an actual disaster and we lost three
astronauts on the launch pad
and yet was sad
but it was considered part of the
process yes
right and we understood
that
even though we take every effort to try
to
avoid those types of situations
actual physical risk and not just
Financial Risk or something like that is
a part of the exploratory process yeah
and if we try to take all the risk out
of the process
then progress is going to just slow down
to a crawl
and particularly and one of the things
that came up during your talk was this
idea of say getting off Earth whether it
be just for curiosity's sake or for
safety's sake in case we blow this place
up or or whatever but if we want to
actually do that we have to recognize
that at some point in that process
things will go wrong and people will die
yeah and we have to be willing to say
you know what yeah it happens and and as
much as we don't like it we're actually
okay with it and we'll do better next
time
and we've become so afraid of that
physical aspect that some of our
innovation has slowed down there's these
different scales of risk there's the
small business scale of risk where it's
just kind of like one person sacrificing
their time and money and then there's
the like large company scale of risk
where if you pivot and try something and
potentially fail that could be
disastrous and then there's like
potentially Country-Wide uh risk as well
where in a country invests into
something and and it's interesting
because we still have these individuals
that are very much into risk you know
the guys that base jump and stuff like
that
but they're not sitting on top of rocket
ships these days because we're not
building enough Rockets right and
there's this fear that you know
somebody's going to sue at some point if
all right so yeah we've got to readjust
our balance when it comes to exploration
and Innovation and be willing to try
things
um it affects a lot more than just you
know Aviation and SpaceX totally the
same thing is going on uh with medicine
for instance yeah the FDA will get in a
lot more trouble if it approves the drug
that ends up killing two or three people
that
not allowing a drug
that would save 10 000 people
right and so 10 000 people die because
they're afraid
that it might hurt two or three yeah and
that's about that right because you
can't prove the negative
right yeah
um they don't get the bad press for
something they didn't do only for
something they did and yeah so there's
things like that that we have to perhaps
rethink as a society if we want to make
the big progress now there are areas
where we're making
huge Innovations but other things where
we've slowed down a lot and some of
those things I think we need to
reevaluate because frankly uh
getting off the Earth is probably more
important to us as a society than
another social networkers
there's so we'll talk about some of the
what you were teaching me about what's
going on with specifically the the like
the South Dakota entrepreneurship and
Innovation ecosystem
um prior to that I just want to hear
what your takeaways have been from
professing Innovation and
Entrepreneurship
as well as you know basically doing a
synthesis of what a lot of leadership
has been teaching about entrepreneurship
and Innovation and then
disseminating it with your own tank
would have been some of those important
takeaways
well
a lot of the stuff that I use is stuff
that will be kind of household names in
Silicon Valley now guys like Eric Reese
and Anderson Alexander osterwalder
Steve blank Bob Dorff and so forth and
what I try to do is to take them all and
just put them together in a nice package
for the students
I think one of the things that's that's
quite interesting though is that
a lot of this stuff has become available
in the last say decade or decade and a
half
and
it's not widely used
outside of the
Silicon Valley extended Community or the
kind of Entrepreneurship community
a lot of that stuff would actually be
quite valuable for large companies as
well
but they have a hard time wrapping their
heads around something that was
developed for entrepreneurs
now
on the one hand I'm okay with that
because you know that's you know more
exciting more exciting stuff going on at
the small scale where we can
uh
get our hands dirty more easily but at
the same time I wish some of these big
businesses would uh loosen up a little
bit
and uh
try out some of these new techniques
that work so well at that small scale
but
now from an international point of view
it's interesting
how the different cultural aspects come
into play
because
with the political social histories of
different countries it impacts
the
approach to risk of individuals
but there's a lot of other factors that
come into play as well so for instance
in Russia
which is the foreign country I have the
most experience with
the education system takes cohorts
really starting in preschool you're with
the same group of kids in preschool for
four years then in elementary school
year with the same group of 30 kids
when you go to college you don't apply
to a college you apply to a major within
the college and you're taking the same
classes with the same group of 30 kids
for all four years and you maybe have
one or two electives your entire four
years
and those electives might even be with
half of your group of 30.
so you don't get to know people
in other disciplines yeah
in an academic setting you might know
them from other social events or
something but you don't understand you
know is this guy a good engineer I'm in
business I don't know if this guy's a
good engineer not because I've never
seen him in the classroom
even
subjects that we in America think
would be natural mixing situations like
a foreign language
or uh
if the engineers have to take a business
class those are done inside the
department they have somebody come in
rather than sending the people over to
the other department right and so what
ends up happening is you get a lot of
people that know their group very well
they know other people in their field
pretty well but
they are not well connected to people in
other disciplines
and one of the most fertile areas for
Innovation is at the intersection of
discipline yes it is
and
so natural Innovation is harder there
now interestingly they have developed
some really
powerful formal techniques for
Innovation and structured Innovation
there's a program called Tris
the theory of inventive problem solving
which is a fairly structured approach to
Innovation and it works pretty well
to a point
but
The Next Step comes on say something
somebody over there thought of something
their natural inclination is to either
publish a paper or apply for a patent
and put the little certificate on their
wall and be done with it because
they don't have the cultural history and
they don't have the examples the role
models Role Models yeah to go out and
start a business around it and that's
one of the things
that we were really focusing on over
there is to help these people get
inspired not just by American
entrepreneurs
but by local entrepreneurs that were
becoming successful not the oligarchs
that you know took over something and
became instant billionaires but somebody
who actually built something from
scratch
and it's going to take a few more years
before we have enough of those in Russia
to
inspire people in different fields that
see it be it applies to every one around
the world to see someone in the field
succeeding in what you're interested in
and then you knowing that you can also
become that also you mentioned the
interdisciplinary or multi-disciplinary
the fields crashing together the
overlaps of them are so crucial for
Innovation and Entrepreneurship exactly
yeah and that actually kind of brings me
back to South Dakota yeah let's do this
because one of the issues that we have
here in South Dakota is
I mean we all know we have a relatively
low population here right
so population per square mile in South
Dakota is 11. in the population per
square mile in San Francisco is 18
000.
okay a little harder to get critical
mass here right
but if you consider the entire State
actually has a population roughly
equivalent or a little less than Metro
Omaha yeah right you see the kind of
problem we're dealing with now it turns
out that in some Fields like biotech we
actually
hit a punch above our weight so to speak
we do considerably better in biotech
than anyone would have a right to expect
given the population
of South Dakota and that's particularly
concentrated in the Sioux Falls Area is
that Sanford and Avera uh not just those
are mostly the medical side of Biotech
but there's others as well like Sab
uh like Prairie Aqua Tech
cool and so forth there's a number of
things and I and my role with USD work
with a number of ones that you haven't
heard of yet and hopefully in a couple
years you will
uh
but we actually do reasonably well
in biotech
but just because we're doing better per
capita than you'd expect
still doesn't give us enough critical
mass to draw some of the heavy hitting
investment from places like Silicon
Valley yeah we'd actually have to do not
just better than the average but four
times better than we're doing now
to generate enough companies here for
somebody to actually say open an office
here or something like that
so we have a bit of a disadvantage and
we also
have a disadvantage of having relatively
few role models and you mentioned
earlier that in places like San
Francisco
and to a lesser degree New York
Boston
you can run into startup CEOs walking
down the street yep
or at very least some fairly highly
placed employee
okay
that doesn't happen as often here
although In fairness
smallness works both ways you're likely
to know the one person but they may not
be in your field
so one of the things that we need here
is a few more examples we don't need a
lot more but a few more examples that
are going to inspire people yeah and we
need to do a little bit better job of
self-promotion and we've got some of
that Midwestern humbleness
holding us back a little bit we don't we
don't like to brag so much because of
you know
the uh I guess the Scandinavian
Norwegian Bachelor Farmers right
those of you that remember A Prairie
Home Companion
so
there was a great show episode on there
once where he said every I think he was
talking about Minnesota but it applies
here too is it everyone needs a personal
New Yorker
be bossy but yeah yeah how are you doing
on that entrepreneurship yeah
just this July
CNBC ranked us about number 20th in
terms of State business climates
and there were two main factors that
were holding us down
we got a lot of A's
couple of C's and two F's the two F's
were in Innovation and Entrepreneurship
and in access to Capital
I think
some of that Innovation and
Entrepreneurship grade is simply because
we don't talk about what we're actually
doing here
we need to do a better job of talking
about the Innovation and
Entrepreneurship that's actually going
on here although let's wait until after
we've shown this F score to the governor
and a few other influencers so that we
can get some more support first and then
we'll start talking about how well we're
doing
but the other one is access to Capital
and that's going to be a tougher nut to
crack and there's a few different
approaches we have some the I6 challenge
grants going the I6 challenge Grant is
going on and I handle USD side of that
and that's where I mentioned some of
these companies that I'm working with
and that was half a million bucks that
is going like twenty five thousand
dollar increase so it's a million dollar
Grant all together between the various
co-matching and and so forth about half
of that approximately half million
dollars is going to twenty five thousand
dollar proof of concept grants for these
uh biotech anything broadly bio uh could
qualify and there's some exciting work
going on there and one of the approaches
we're taking is people that are working
on say human use Medical
type Technologies we're finding
alternate markets where they can get
into the market without the regulatory
burden and start making money
and use that flow of cash to support
their research and their validation so
that they can not be so dependent on
grant funding and so forth so that's an
exciting way
to to approach things
so we're seeing some exciting stuff
going on there
um but we also need to
free up some of the private capital
because
we can't just rely on government grants
to fund growth in South Dakota because
it's not going to happen
um
but there are some exciting things going
on South Dakota Equity Partners just
closed their first fund
at uh 16 million dollars at their first
close that's great which is Tiny money
by Silicon Valley standards but it's a
start definitely
um
it's still though it's a post-revenue
fund and our biggest hole is in the kind
of seed stage you know between that
proof of concept money and when you're
actually generating cash there needs to
be some private investment that you can
get me through that stage there's a
reason why even in Silicon Valley that
range is called the Valley of Death yeah
yeah
but
it's a bigger problem here because
unlike Silicon Valley we don't
typically have you know
multi-millionaire neighbors that say Hey
cool idea here's five million bucks go
with it
I was at a talk with one of the founders
of Zynga
and he actually gave that in his example
and I was thinking
that's nice for you guys but it's
completely useless for entrepreneurs
outside of Silicon Valley because that
just doesn't happen anywhere else yeah
the rest of us have to
meal
pull that money out of
you know it's like pulling blood out of
a stone right it's uh much harder in the
rest of the world and around the world
exactly it's like that yeah so we have
to to find and one of the things I would
like to see is
some local successes at the seed yeah
Angel level that will inspire more local
investors to
allocate five percent of their portfolio
towards more interesting stuff and not
just
on Wall Street or whatever but actually
stuff that's going to generate activity
here in South Dakota you can make money
and make good money
while actually promoting the local
economy that's a win-win a lot of people
don't realize that
the most successful class of investing
is Angel Investing if you have a large
enough portfolio right and do due
diligence and stuff like that
it takes a little work to generate that
size of a portfolio around here because
you know deal flow and so forth is more
limited just because of our our size but
I think it can happen and I think if we
do it right we can generate some great
returns for investors and some exciting
activity here in Sioux Falls Eastern
South Dakota all of South Dakota
there's great stuff going on
out in in the Black Hills School of
Mines
so you know seems like we need success
stories about this that's what I was
about to get at is you know follow
around these success stories with with
videography capture what they're doing
highlight that through the news stations
Keloland case why highlight that show it
to other both young kids and investors
to allocate the percentages of their
portfolios even a small percent like
five percent into seed stage companies
in the area and then also we we talked
briefly about sort of doing things like
X prizes in the area these sort of like
what you're doing right now is awarding
000 bucks to biotech companies that are
showing some successful progress enough
to give them that that money and ability
to to try and so this seems to be like a
reoccurring theme is where are the most
important areas to Target for each
Community there is some stuff going on
right now one of the big things is the
governor's diet Vision competition which
Awards 25 000 each year to the most
promising
uh Innovative small business
and there's also a student level which I
think is five thousand dollars
but I think one of the keys is more
follow-up with that awarding cash is
great but I think we need to the New
Yorker
that's right there well yes but uh not
necessarily that so much as
the mentor that goes along with
everybody yeah because when you look at
at studies of what determines success
and failure and Entrepreneurship
okay
the greatest cause of failure is product
Market mismatch you're making something
that people don't want right the
greatest cause of success is a good
Mentor yeah now that's probably because
good mentors help you figure out that
mismatch and get it fixed early on early
on so that you don't have the main cause
of failure but
the guidance is invaluable absolutely
and and sometimes it's not
necessarily that the mentor has to have
any particular expertise although that's
often quite useful but sometimes it's
just
taking your ideas and talking about them
with another person right thinking
through them out loud rather than by
yourself can make a big difference now
if that person can give good feedback as
well that then adds even more value yeah
right
but
it's a bit of a problem here because of
again the population issue we have
relatively fewer mentors available than
in other places okay that was that was a
problem in Russia too because all the
successful businessmen are young enough
that they're still right in the middle
of business and really busy and the
people that are old enough to be retired
were all
soviet-trained Soviet mindset and
therefore not very good mentors
fortunately we don't have that problem
here
that's such an important question to ask
ourselves though is who do I have that's
a mentor to me so when we ask ourselves
that question it's sort of it takes us
into oh well who is my top Mentor who
are my top three mentors who are the
people that I call with my ideas so they
can hit the tennis ball back and augment
the idea teach me what I'm missing my
blind spots so how who are those mentors
and and
so how many of us have mentors in here
give some noise for people that have
mentors yeah yeah okay okay so so that
you said is the is the largest
a sort of a sister of success of an
entrepreneur yeah the research shows
that a good Mentor is the
single biggest factor in being a
successful entrepreneur
got to make that happen with more people
than more mentors for more young people
yeah so okay why don't we uh Zeal is a
great resource yeah that
shout out to Thad shout out to Thad and
Zeal Center yeah places like this so
there's also like mentorship communities
as well where you can go and and focus
and build there with other builders yeah
right and like I'm available uh for free
to anybody that's got some sort of
affiliation with USD uh you know for
other people well we'll talk
um
but uh yeah so there are some resources
available here well one of the things we
need to do is to make them more visible
make sure that everybody knows how to
access them and you know
you know who else besides
Zeal and me uh
is around that you can talk to that you
can explore ideas with
yup
there's things in town like one Million
Cups we have a very active One Million
Cups group so starting January 30th 9
A.M at the Museum of Visual Arts every
Wednesday
come out
meet other entrepreneurs
hear from people that are making it work
some of them will have issues that you
might be able to help with or vice versa
teach us about the March 29th date
so March 29th is a little competition
that we have done at USD
it's called eye to eye or invent to
innovate
it's a competition for high schoolers
and college students
and
we are hoping to get participation from
say call it Greater South East South
Dakota so everywhere from Sioux Falls to
Sioux City
at the high school level and then at the
college level uh
we welcome people from just about
anywhere
uh if if you can't travel here we'll
make special arrangements for for video
competition but we have a
a two thousand dollar grand prize for
the college level of a thousand dollar
grand prize for the high school levels
and uh it's a business model competition
so you present your model more or less
in the business model generation
business model canvas type of
format
and uh last year we had
four college teams and 14 high school
teams participate so we we need to boost
the number of college teams a little bit
the high school participation we need to
broaden the geographic scope more than
the numbers
and that also does that crowdsourcing of
ideas which I love so much because then
they're you're receiving tons of
different business plans on how to solve
potential issues or create businesses
it's interesting when you look at things
like this
how
a lot of people have very similar ideas
like last year at the high school level
there were two teams working on uh
different assistive Technologies for
deaf people right
um stuff like that so
people are
gravitating towards certain types of
problems understanding and recognizing
that they are problems and trying to
come up with Solutions and you see these
same problems recurring and coming to
people's minds that indicates that
there's something there that somebody
ought to address now whether it ends up
being those high school teams
or whether it ends up being somebody
else
that's to be determined
but what it does tell you there's an
opportunity there what would you say is
one of the main ways to help with the
follow through because we made that joke
about a New Yorker and we made the
reference about mentors as well what's
the main way to follow through even for
the companies that are getting these
twenty five thousand or five thousand
one thousand so something that we did in
New Jersey
that I haven't had I've only been here
for for one year so I haven't had time
to put this kind of thing together and
it will require finding some additional
funding and so forth but
with the companies that won our
competition at New Jersey
they didn't win money although
money can still be useful
they won
eight weeks of coaching
that's cool and
that
can often be much more valuable it helps
than the money
in fact I remember the head of the
Russian Venture company saying it at one
of the Venture fairs where I was
speaking
that uh
the knowledge or the intellectual help
can often be far more valuable than
simply the financial and in Russia that
was a problem because they had lots of
money but they didn't have a lot of
people with
the actual mentoring skills so they
could
invest a lot of money in the startup
economy there and they are
proportionally they're investing huge
amounts of money into Innovation and
startups but they're lacking that
critical factor that mentorship yeah
here
that mentorship is out there we just
have to be better at building the
connections building connections yeah
and then also you mentioned that it was
it was really interesting when you were
taught you to me it was like a bunch of
young people are trying to arrange
different successful businesses and
that's the whole tons and tons of kind
of permutations of successful businesses
are going on across the world in that
sense and how do you get more funding
into the seed stages of these ideas
being developed and the job creation
numbers are there it's and job creation
is huge for economic flourishing so
these things all piece together in this
Innovation and Entrepreneurship Arena
and the more we sort of study it and
understand it and and immerse ourselves
in it the better we ourselves get at it
and make progress in it
um
quick question on on the way out and
then we'll open up for some questions
um
what is there's the book The one thing
the do what is the one thing you have to
do when you wake up in the morning
what's that one action item an afternoon
what's the action item evening what's
the action item what would you say is
one of the best action items in a habit
for an entrepreneur an innovator to
carry
it really there's two different groups
that are involved in Innovation and
the advice would be different for these
two different groups
people who are naturally innovative
one of the biggest problems they have is
focusing yeah so take somebody like Elon
Musk how many companies is Elon Musk
running now like five five yeah okay now
some of those had
there's there's no question they'd be
doing better if he were devoting all of
his time
to one instead of bouncing back and
forth across five
okay
so
one of them is focus I've known people
that could toss off an invention to get
a new patent every week
but
they could never run a successful
company because they're too busy chasing
the new thing and can't settle down and
focus on one
you have another group of people
where the biggest problem is they're not
trying new things
so two opposite problems in these two
different things we need the one group
to try new things and
somewhere there's an opportunity to have
these idea generators over here feed
things over here and have these people
take them and run with them yeah yeah
but nobody's worked out the model yet to
to make that like the whole idea tank
and the execution tank exactly
so think
what
of those two models fits you best
and then
bring some of the other one into your
life so if you're an execution person
find a way to bring more ideas in and if
you're an idea person figure out how to
focus and actually follow through on
these ideas yeah yeah because
it sounds really weird from an
individual level to say this but ideas
are cheap yeah 99.9 execution yeah yeah
for myself
it feels really weird to say it because
ideation is hard
but at the same time the fact of the
matter is that in the real world there
are a lot more ideas than there are
people who can carry them out yes right
and so it turns out that ideas are
actually cheap
yeah and being able
to make them happen
is what's so valuable yeah
so if we can do better job at matching
those two things up
we can see a lot of progress that was a
really great thanks that was a really
good wrap I like that a lot yeah it's
like get executing and become a good
executor and help execute ideas and
teach other people how to do design and
Ops and engineering and and marketing
and sales and get stuff out there and
start innovating
um this has been this has been great
there's been a lot of of of new ways of
perceiving innovation and
Entrepreneurship that you've taught us
about Aaron
um
so thank you for joining us we'll take
some questions really appreciate you
teaching us thank you so much
um
questions from the audience
yes
on what they do but like what are some
major differences in why
well Russia suffers from having an
economic monoculture so
70 percent of the Russian economy is
tied to hydrocarbons
oil gas in fact to a degree that
for a while
you could correlate the price of the
ruble with the price of oil
said
the two things that we're not doing well
are talking about our ideas we're
talking about what we're doing and
capital
uh are there is there a physical space
or a an event that is not happening in
this region that should be
I I really think that
in terms of
events
that we do quite well
considering
Sioux Falls I again I've only been here
a year I have been Amazed by how dynamic
a City Sioux Falls is for a city that is
under a quarter million in population
it's just amazing how much stuff is
going on here
we need to do a little bit better job of
communicating within our and amongst
ourselves as to what all is going on you
can find it if you look for it but it's
not always obvious
in terms of physical space for other
things
um
there's definitely some issues at the
University level but that could be a
whole nother
talk or you know
one of the problems that we have at the
University level is that we're dealing
with decisions that were made 150 years
ago in terms of where the universities
are and
what the different universities are
allowed to
teach and specialize in and so forth so
for instance the University of South
Dakota which is the flagship State
University
the only engineering we have is
biomedical engineering that's because
there's this Arrangement within the
regental system where traditional
engineering is handled at mines and and
South Dakota state
and then you know Dakota state has the
focus on Cyber stuff
and we
have the professional schools and the
liberal arts
but what that means is that
the business students
don't have the inter interaction
opportunities with the engineering
students because the engineering
students are either at the arch enemy
school or they're at mines which is five
and a half hours away
right
we have to find a way to overcome
those social cultural barriers that were
established 150 years ago when we
decided where the universities would be
and recognize that we can be fierce
enemies on the football field
but we still need to be hand in hand
working together in Innovation and
Entrepreneurship because
in a state with the population of South
Dakota we can't afford to be
at loggerheads with each other we have
to be working together
like I said
we've got a population
in the whole state roughly the same as
Metro Omaha right
um
so we can't get the critical mass that
we need if we're going to be
siled in these different places we have
to be willing to come together as a
state and say I don't care whether
This research was done at USD or mines
or SDSU or or whatever I think it's a
cool Tech and I want to cooperate to
make it happen
last question
as you discussed
11 11 people participate
like
there are Industries which require huge
Manpower in Saudi Arabia
as to these industries the requirements
but Manpower is less here still this
Industries are available
on the other hand there are Industries
like I.T they don't need much Manpower
but still
it's not successful in South Africa
so what is the reason
well the reason why for instance medical
has been successful is because of
historical factors
in academics we call it path dependence
we have a couple of systems that got
started here
that have grown here
they're headquartered here Avera and
Sanford
because of their history or the
naturally going to employ a lot of
people
i t on the other hand
one of the things that we need to do is
support
our I.T people
and give them as really goes back to
that mentorship issue
and there's some things I'm working on I
can't discuss yet that hopefully will
help on the capital side
but
if we can get that mentorship going one
of the advantages of a lot of the I.T
things is that they are not location
dependent
right you can do a web company
literally anywhere in the world
and it doesn't matter where you're
located
right
so
once we recognize that one of the things
that we could do I think we ought to be
poaching firms from Silicon Valley
saying Hey look
you can come here
and
your burn rate is going to be cut by 70
percent compared to being in the Bay
Area
okay
and
Maybe
it's going to be a little bit harder to
find as many top end
programmers or whatever as you need
but hire twice as many
they're you know there is an old saying
in the military that quantity has a
quality all its own
um and I think we could use a little bit
of that approach in the IIT and startup
world as well uh
we can be competitive here because we
have a lot of other advantages you know
you build a company in Silicon Valley
it's going to cost you tens of millions
of dollars just to get to the point
where you can have
10 employees and around here you can do
it for under a million bucks
right and I'm talking real estate and
employees and everything
so there's a lot of advantages here in
that respect yeah
okay now I will grant you the weather
here is a little colder
they asked me if it would be a problem
for me and I told them no I've lived in
Siberia this is not a not an issue for
me but for other people it's going to be
a
a bit of a you know
perception barrier at first right oh
isn't it cold up there in South Dakota
well
once you've
done a South Dakota winter you know how
to adapt to it it's really not that big
a deal to
be careful on these roads
but there's a lot of reasons I mean
if you look at some of the reports that
Sioux Falls was just named one of the
best cities to retire Rapid City has
long been a place that's attracted
people for retirement because of the
Black Hills so there's a lot of
things here that can attract people we
need to play up our strengths
thank you Aaron what a pleasure this has
been thank you so much thank you really
appreciate you coming on the show and
chatting with us here at Zeal Center
thanks everyone for coming out really
appreciate it stick around
[Applause]
a bit oh